- C'est une ancienne base
militaire soviétique, à 3 heures
de route de la frontière russe.
Ici, ce sont les quelques
500 militaires canadiens qui
dirigent la mission, appuyés par
des soldats de 9 autres pays.
(explosion)
Les premiers militaires ont
été déployés en 2017, quelques
années après l'annexion
de la Crimée.
Frédéric Tremblay et
William Lebel, deux soldats
originaires de la région
de Québec, sont arrivés ici
en décembre, avant que
Vladimir Poutine ne lance
son invasion en Ukraine.
Ici aussi, on se prépare en cas
d'attaque russe, même si William
n'est pas très craintif.
WILLIAM LEBEL, Forces armées
canadiennes
- Mettons, moi personnellement,
je serais prêt là.
- Malgré cette confiance,
Frederic reçoit parfois
des messages d'inquiétudes
de la part de ses proches.
FRÉDÉRIC TREMBLAY, Forces armées
canadiennes
- On rassure nos proches que
tout est correct et que, pour
l'instant, ça bouge pas là.
- Après avoir échangé avec
quelques militaires,
Justin Trudeau annonceun proloni
de la mission en Lettonie,
qui devait se terminer en 2023.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU, premier ministre
du Canada
- On va continuer d'être là pour
défendre la démocratie en Europe
et partout dans le monde.
- Quand on lui demande s'il est
prêt à aller en guerre si
Vladimir Poutine pénètre ne
serait ce qu'un centimètre àààà
l'intérieur d'un pays de l'OTAN,
le premier ministre canadien est
clair.
- L'OTAN est plus uni que jamais
et déterminé à démontrer
cette unité à tous les jours.
Et je peux parler pour tous
les membres de l'OTAN quand
je dis que nous allons tous
suivre l'article 5.
- Un article qui stipule
qu'une attaque contre un pays
de l'alliance est considérée
comme une agression contre
tous les membres.JENS STOLTENBEe
général de l'OTAN
- Le président russe veut
freiner l'expansion de l'OTAN,
mais il ne fait que
la renforcer, ajoute
le secrétaire général
de l'organisation. Cet expert
prévient qu'une telle escalade
serait lourde de conséquences.
RICHARD BLANCHETTE, major
général à la retraite
- Ce serait véritablement
un défi, car les Russes ont
à leur portée tout ce qui touche
à l'arsenal nucléaire.
- C'est e qu'on
retrouve, en ce moment, le plus
important déploiement militaire
canadien à l'étranger. Et pour
le gouvernement Trudeau, qui
se fait reprocher de ne pas
suffisamment dans
le secteur de la défense et
de tarder à renouveler
son équipement militaire,
la visite d'aujourd'hui estl'ocr
qu'il est tout de même(-ué úadté
auprès de ses alliés.
Ici Laurence Martin,
Radio-Canada, à la base
militaire d'Adazi